billions of years ago another planet
smashed into Earth an event of this
epicness could have created our moon it
also could have brought alien life to
our
planet what evidence of this planet
still exists on Earth
today could there be life deep inside
the Earth's
surface and could that that life be an
advanced civilization of humanoid
aliens this is what if and here's what
would happen if aliens are living inside
the
earth 4 and a half billion years ago
Thea a protoplanet the size of Mars
struck our young Earth this Collision
scattered pieces of both planets into
space and many scientists argue that
these pieces eventually coalesced into
our
moon but what happened to the rest of
Thea is still a
mystery the existence of blobs of
material inside Earth's mantle known as
low sheer velocity provinces could be
evidence that parts of Thea fused with
Earth these chunks are up to 1,000 km in
height and several times that in width
they sit below Africa and the Pacific
Ocean straddling Earth's core like a
pair of
headphones but other theories some
dating back centuries suggest a
completely different explanation of what
exists under the surface a lush tropical
Paradise for
aliens the Earth consists of four layers
the crust the mantle and the outer and
inner core but there had hasn't been any
successful exploration below the crust
so there's much we don't know about the
realities below the surface this has led
to spectacular speculation like the
hollow Earth theory according to this
Theory our planet could be a series of
nested spheres centered around a central
core in between these shells atmospheres
could exist that are capable of
supporting life in the 17th century
Edmund hiy the scientist who discovered
hi's Comet backed this Theory many
others have added to it suggesting a
small Sun could be hanging in the center
of the earth and plants animals and
humans could be living there and not
just humans but a race of
superhumans Immortals who possess
sophisticated technology to build
hundreds of subterranean cities but if
there were aliens inside the earth what
would the conditions for life be could
the inside of our planet be a luscious
Paradise or a hot hellish
dump if you were to visit one of the low
sheer velocity provinces you'd have to
go 2900 km below the surface here you'd
be surrounded by magma or liquid rock
with temperatures as high as 3700 de
C and the weight of the crust and mantle
above you would increase the pressure to
over
237,000 times the atmospheric pressure
you know on the surface of the
Earth whatever life you find here would
need to exist in these extreme
conditions and these life forms would
need to evolve to extract oxygen
directly from the magma or live without
it they'd need to survive without any
sunlight radiation would be the primary
energy source and lucky for them the
radioactive decay of uranium thorium and
potassium in the Earth's crust and
mantle already account for the primary
source of heat in the Earth's
interior there could be all kinds of
undiscovered creatures down there but
until you could withstand the pressure
and heat to find out we'll never
know there are billions of planets in
the universe that theoretically can
support
life but so far we haven't discovered
any aliens out
there maybe the reason is we're just
looking in the wrong
places what if alien life isn't anything
like the life we know of what if it
doesn't need water or oxygen what if it
can withstand incredibly hot
temperatures or very acidic
environments and what would we need to
search for to finally find
it this is what if and here's what would
happen if alien life was silicon
based there's one one thing that your
DNA a diamond and a rubber duck have in
common they're all made of
carbon carbon is one of the most
abundant elements in the
universe on Earth it's also the primary
building block of all
life carbon is so special because its
atoms can make four bonds with another
element oxygen and form long chains of
atoms called
polymers but there's another element
that can do the same trick
silicon not only is silicon chemically
similar to carbon it also makes it on
the list of the most plentiful chemicals
found in the
universe potentially silicon could be a
building block of organic alien life and
we might find that life in our own solar
system a candidate for hosting a
silicon-based alien life is hiding among
the moons of Saturn
Titan the biggest of these moons has an
atmosphere that's 95% nitrogen and 5%
methane it has no oxygen and any water
it has is frozen solid because Titan
receives only 1% of the amount of
sunlight the Earth
does but silicon-based life forms
wouldn't need any water instead they
could use Liquid methane as the galactic
Elixir for their
existence the lack of oxygen would also
be essential for such life to emerge
here's why when carbon unites with
oxygen or oxidizes as it does during a
fire it turns into a gas carbon
dioxide now when silicon oxidizes it
becomes silicon dioxide or silica which
is a solid and not a
gas if Titan had oxygen in its
atmosphere silicon would immediately
turn into rock and no life could
possibly begin in that state but Titan's
atmosphere doesn't contain any Oxygen
giving silicon-based life a
chance what would this life look
like how big would the Silicon species
be would they build their own
civilization or invent their own
language well most likely if there is
silicon based life out there it would be
in the form of microbes and not
animalized organisms that you can see
with your own
eyes scientists generally agree that any
silicon-based life would need intense
heat to survive so most likely you'd
have to dig deep under the surface of
Titan to find
it because of the extreme cold on
Titan's surface a living being would
live somewhere close to Titan's core
where it's
hot and hey they're are many planets out
there some of them might just have the
right conditions for non-carbon-based
life to
thrive because silicon doesn't get along
with oxygen the metabolic processes of a
silicon-based organism would have to be
entirely different from ours we don't
know if it's even possible just as we
don't know if anything strictly silicon
based would have a
DNA but maybe we shouldn't try applying
our science to alien in life we've never
encountered and planets we haven't
thoroughly
explored Earth's conditions don't really
give silicon any chance to form into a
life form but if one day aliens came
down to visit us here on Earth they
would probably change everything we know
about what living organisms could be
made
[Music]
of what if you found out that you had a
long lost relative
and what if that long lost relative was
from a different planet in our galaxy
and what if this far away planet was
home to billions of humans just like
Earth but these humans don't look
anything like us because they're from
the
future could aliens be future versions
of human
humans how far ahead of us would they
be how much would they have
evolved would we be able to understand
each
other and what would meeting future
humans mean for Humanity on
Earth this is what if and here's what
would happen if aliens were future
humans in 1947 a mysterious object
crashed in the desert near Roswell New
Mexico you all know this story but could
it really be
aliens the mysterious object was
officially declared to be a US Army Air
Force balloon but then decades later US
Navy Commander George W Hoover who had
top secret clearance revealed that the
mysterious crash involved time traveling
humans somehow these future humans had
developed the technology to overcome the
technological limitations that prevent
us present day humans from making the
same type of
trip some theories suggest that these
future humans travel back in time in
order to understand their biological
past maybe these same time travelers
helped our ancestors to make huge leaps
in scientific
technological knowledge in a relatively
short amount of
time but if any of these theories are
true should we be prepared for another
alien human visit sometime in the near
future and what might we expect from
this Close Encounter of the Third
Kind if aliens I mean future humans were
to come and visit us again they would
probably look similar to how they appear
appear in
movies like us they'd still walk on two
feet but their heads and their eyes
would be much
larger this fits with predictions of how
present day humans will continue to
evolve we can expect our heads to be
bigger and our upper skull to become
more rounded to accommodate a larger
brain and as our civilization advances
enough for interplanetary travel our
eyes would get big bigger so we can see
better in dimmer environments that are
further away from the
Sun future humans might also find a way
to slow the aging
process so it would be possible to make
several trips to places thousands of
light years away within one lifetime if
we want to travel somewhere that's
60,000 light years away and if our
technology could do it then it would be
a 60-year flight for any anyone on board
but when they got back to Earth 60,000
years would have passed we'd like to
think that humans of the future would
solve this problem so they could visit
Earth and come home to tell their family
and friends about their
trip but if future humans find a way to
live for thousands of years would that
lead to a massive overpopulation on
whichever Planet they
inhabit well chances are if they make it
possible to live that long they will
probably succeed in optimizing their
existence before that their civilization
would undoubtedly be a lot more
efficient than ours the reason being is
that they could be centuries if not
Millennia ahead of us in evolutionary
terms future humans would be a lot
smarter and they'd have better
technology to maximize their space and
live in densely populated worlds without
producing the same high levels of
pollution that we do on Earth in fact
you could bet that future humans
wouldn't just have better technology
they'd be
technology just like some humans today
have implants to perceive sound or to
detect atmospheric pressure the humans
of the future would likely have dozens
of technological implants to make their
lives
easier think about everything your cell
phone does for you
now imagine you could command it with
your thoughts and that it would only be
a small chip in your
brain a chip or implant like that might
also explain why those who claim to have
encountered aliens have said that the
aliens spoke to them in their native
language could future humans simply have
automatic language translators implanted
in their brains or would humans of the
future evolve past different languages
instead using one universal language
like espiranto
something is emerging from the Mariana
Trench and it does not belong on this
planet if aliens lived in the deepest
place in the ocean what would they look
like how would they communicate with one
another and and what would happen if we
dared to contact
them this is what if and here's what
would happen if there were aliens at the
bottom of the Mariana Trench there's a
reason why the idea of aliens living at
the bottom of the sea keeps popping up
in popular culture many of us are far
more afraid of what lies down there than
whatever's looking down at us from up
and in space after all 80% of the ocean
is still unmapped and unexplored we have
better maps of the Moon Mars and Venus
than we do of our sea floor the most
mysterious part of our oceans is the
Mariana Trench its deepest point the
Challenger Deep stretches 11 kilm down
the Mariana Trench is anything but a
great vacation spot no light is able to
reach its bottom and temperatures are
just a few degrees above
freezing not to mention it's crushingly
high water
pressure so how could aliens survive the
deepest spot in the
ocean the water pressure at the bottom
of the Mariana Trench is over 1,000
times the atmospheric pressure that
you're used to at sea level this kind of
pressure would crush anything even the
toughest deep sea robots we've ever
built but some living things managed to
adapt and Thrive under such pressing
conditions like translucent snailfish
and sea cucumbers the hi highle
snailfish known as the deepest living
fish flourishes at depths of over 8
km like you deep sea fish don't have
pockets to store air in their bodies
that oxygen inside your lungs is what
gives you the feeling of pressure
whenever you take a dive no air means
this fish has a higher tolerance to the
weight of all that water Above It
Whatever aliens were lurking down below
would share the same
characteristic storing air just wouldn't
be their thing but what what would they
do for
food well it's likely they'd imitate
their seafloor neighbors once again deep
sea creatures gorge on the decaying
remains of microbes algae or animals
from above our sunken ships might be
their version of a surprise Buffet any
extraterrestrial life down at the pit of
the trench would probably eat similar
food they'd burrow into the biggest
carcasses they could find and consume
what's left from the inside out like a
giant hagfish does or they might possess
enormous mouths and expandable
stomachs allowing them to catch and
digest large quantities of food as they
move and those big mouths of theirs
would also be filled with long fangs
pointed inward this would enable them to
catch and hold on to to other deep sea
creatures or you know any other prey
that just so happens to dive a little
too far from the surface hey don't judge
them in a habitat as precarious as the
Mariana Trench aliens would need to
capitalize on any and all sources of
nutrition they'd also have to go the
extra mile in order to let one another
know that they're out there in the pitch
dark that's because sunlight can only
travel a to 1 km into the ocean anywhere
deeper than that and you wouldn't be
able to see a thing so how would our
underwater aliens put the notice out
that they're
around well two ideas by sound and by
light they produce themselves like
fireflies deep sea creatures are able to
produce and emit their own light thanks
to a process called
bioluminescence with it aliens would be
able to connect with each other through
specific lighting patterns for
long-distance communication they could
send out sound waves across enormous
distances in the water like the humpback
whale who's able to sing in the
Caribbean and be heard off the west
coast of Ireland 6,400 km
away now what would first contact with
this underwater species look like for us
Well we'd have to get there first we'd
need a vessel strong enough to withstand
the constantly intensifying pressure the
tiniest of cracks would squash you and
your submarine faster than you can say
human Jam once down there we'd have to
take into account that living at the
bottom of the sea would be like living
on another planet if aliens existed in
the otherworldly death depths of the
Mariana Trench this entire
time they may not want to be friendly
neighbors and the Darkness alone would
make it difficult to locate and study
our
subjects before approaching these
extraterrestrials we'd have to assess
their communication style first slowly
and patiently we'd need to understand
how they interact with their environment
too that is assuming they don't feel
threat Ed by our presence and decide to
do something about it trust goes both
ways when you're trying not to be
crushed or eaten in the name of
science Houston we have a problem the
ship is experiencing engine malfunction
hyperdrive not functioning something's
wrong
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you crashed on an alien
planet you've traveled thousands of
light years through Interstellar star
systems and now you're stranded on a
planet you know nothing
about as long as you've got oxygen water
and food aboard your
spaceship you should stay inide side and
figure out what you've got going on
around you but your supplies wouldn't
last forever so the clock would be
ticking now you didn't crash on an alien
world just to die your mission is to
collect any information you can on this
planet and try to survive in the
process before you even got a glimpse of
your surroundings the there's one thing
you'd need to figure out it's the
gravity of the planet you landed on sure
it could be just like back home but the
chances of that would be pretty low
realistically this world's gravity would
be something You' need to get used to it
could be lower than on Earth and you'd
feel lighter over time it would make
your vision blurred your muscle shrink
and your back hurt
a lot but if it was stronger than on
Earth well you'd feel heavier and maybe
it would even be strong enough to keep
you pinned to the ground or even break
your
bones next you'd need to find out what
kind of star this alien planet is
orbiting and where in the star system
it's
positioned there's a high chance that
you'd be on an exoplanet orbiting the
most common type of star in the in the
universe a red dwarf many of the 4,000
exoplanets we've discovered orbit these
but red dwarfs are smaller and cooler
than our own Sun so the planet you've
landed on would have to orbit its star
at a distance much closer than Earth
orbits the Sun at least if you wanted it
to be habitable with liquid water on the
surface but being this close could
result in a harsh environment if the
star was only a few billion years old
you'd need ways to protect yourself from
the high energy blasts of ultraviolet
and x-ray
radiation if you couldn't Shield
yourself you'd need to seek shelter
underground otherwise you'd suffer from
long-term radiation
exposure this would cause cataracts make
you sterile and greatly increase your
risk of
cancer while you're observing the star
you need to take note of whether there's
a sunrise and sunset or is it that the
Sun never seems to move in the sky this
would be another danger of being so
close to its star your new home planet
could be tidily locked this means that
one side of the world would always
experience daylight and the other side
would always be shrouded in darkness and
it wouldn't just be a matter of light
and dark it would also mean that one
side would be scorching hot and the
other would be freezing cold you'd be on
a planet caught between two extremes and
your best bet for surviving would be to
head toward the Terminator line this
would be the thin strip of land between
the day side and the night side here
you'd have a Goldilocks situation where
it's not too hot and not too cold but
you'd also have the incredible treat of
NeverEnding Dusk and
Dawn the next thing you'd want to assess
is whether you'd have an atmosphere that
you could
breathe just because it's in the
habitable zone wouldn't mean it's
habitable for you youd need oxygen lucky
for you astronomers found that
exoplanets with breathable air are more
common than you might think but keep
your oxygen tank close by as you
experiment with breathing out there as
an astronaut you've already been exposed
to many of the hardships that come with
the job like living with different
levels of gravity various magnetic
fields and of course psychological
stress but landing on an alien planet
you'd have a few more things to add to
the list if you had a weak immune system
you could be vulnerable to infection
from microorganisms we've never seen
before that would make you patient zero
on a planet where you'd be the closest
thing to a doctor researchers suggest
that all kinds of lethal bacteria or
viruses could survive in the extremely
harsh conditions of space so you'd need
to take precautions and not even just
for your own protection but for the
possible life on this Alien Planet you'd
be carrying who knows how many pathogens
and microorganisms from back on Earth
these could kill or wipe out organisms
that you haven't even detected yet
speaking of which could there be life on
this planet you've crashed
into well if you wanted to find out your
best bet would be to head to the nearest
source of water
don't get overly excited just yet the
most likely possibility is that you'd
only discover microorganisms but that
wouldn't completely rule out the chances
that intelligent life could be waiting
for you around any Corner if you did
make first contact with an intelligent
life form the first thing you'd have to
do would be to try communicating with it
after all you wouldn't want to make the
most amazing disc Y in human history
only for them to kill you out of fear or
aggression you could try using linos a
Dutch mathematician invented this
language in the 1960s and he meant it
for one purpose only to speak with
aliens you'd start slow and develop the
language further so both you and the
aliens can understand first you'd need
to make sure that they grasp the concept
of numbers and then you'd move on to
complex Concepts like love or
death but the chances would be higher
that you would land on a planet with
seemingly no intelligent life you'd be
all alone no humans or aliens to talk to
spending thousands of hours in total
isolation you could eventually suffer
from hallucinations and hear voices in
your head
this would be your new reality but all
of this wouldn't change the fact that
you want to
survive you'd have to keep your wits
about you and put any planetary
resources you can find to
use you might not be back home for a
while and in the meantime you'd still
have to eat if there were any alien life
forms walking past you you might start
looking at them like they're cartoon
roast
[Music]
chickens what if the moon was more than
just a lifeless Rock under that bright
light it could be hiding an alien
civilization when did this alien life
begin on the
moon what would these lunar dwellers
breathe
and what would our neighbors look
like this is what if and here's what
would happen if aliens lived on the
moon until Galileo showed up on the
scene with his telescope all we knew
about the moon was that it was bright
and shiny while we certainly know more
now its Origins are still a
mystery yeah we still don't know how the
moon became
well the
moon some scientists think a chunk of
the Earth broke off about 4 and 1 half
billion years ago after a violent
collision with another planet all the
debris eventually came together to form
this body and the moon landing in
1969 did more than Inspire Humanity to
reach the Stars it made this rock
something real to humans everywhere
but we didn't stay for long so what if
the astronauts missed something big up
there the lunar surface is a rough place
to live without an atmosphere there's no
protection from the sun's radiation or
even a way to keep oxygen on the ground
but maybe it wasn't always like this
after that piece of Earth broke off
microscopic life like cyanobacteria
could have survived in this harsh
environment we call this the panspermia
theory the idea that life can be
transferred by meteoroids asteroids or
even
spaceships considering the moon orbits
Us in the habitable zone there could
have been a time billions of years ago
when it had fresh water and volcanic
activity could have release the gases
needed to sustain
life so why isn't there life there
now well who's to say there isn't when
these conditions existed the moon could
have incubated life for hundreds of
millions of years before humans existed
while dinosaurs roamed our planet the
moon could have been teaming with life
that would look stranger than some of
those
behemoths the moon's magnetic field is a
fraction as powerful as the Earth's so
over millions of years solar winds
Stripped Away all of its atmosphere with
nothing to protect it life on the
surface would have to adapt to survive
the sun's intense Rays on Earth melanin
in our skin protects us from ultraviolet
rays but instead of having a darker skin
tone the moon aliens could have
developed new
colors carotenoids are organic pigments
found in vegetables like carrots and
they contain cells that protect against
skin cancer if the aliens evolved to
have carotenoids instead of melanin they
might have tough orange skin that would
resist the dangerous UV rays around
them and the differences don't end there
since the moon's gravity is only one
sixth of that on Earth these aliens
could get around by jumping or
gliding but without an atmosphere
holding oxygen on the surface what would
these creatures
breathe well even with an atmosphere
that's only 100th as thick as ours that
doesn't mean that life can't exist
recently scientists have found a
parasite that doesn't need oxygen to
live maybe over millions of years these
aliens could have evolved in the same
way without breathing well
anything now while this diversity of
life might exist on the surface you
couldn't say the same for the lunar
oceans I mean if they
existed while the average ocean on earth
goes down 3.7 km the moon's Seas would
only have a depth of 1 km there's not
much that could be found in these Waters
but if life did exist on the moon how
would that have changed our history well
if these aliens had evolved before
Humanity they might have visited us
before we landed on the moon and if they
had waited until after the Space Race
the increasing tensions of the Cold War
might never have happened instead humans
could have United in fear over an
invasion from a superior life form the
militaries around the globe would have
deployed counter measures to assess the
threats these visitors pose and as
scientists and politicians tried to
communicate with our Celestial neighbors
everyone else would be hunkered down
Racing for the
worst you know sharing our corner of the
solar system with a much more advanced
civilization might be overwhelming but
it's either that or an allout war and
considering how how much more evolved
these aliens are we might want to think
of a peaceful solution or hey we might
get along so well that eventually our
two species could become one what if you
took it to the extreme and made it with
an
alien it was love First Sight wasn't it
wasn't it
doodle It's a beautiful night just you a
bottle of wine and your partner drifting
through the cosmos in a
UFO as you caress their green skin you
know that tonight's the night you're
mating with an
alien but would your Anatomy be
compatible how would conception take
place and what would your child look
like
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you made it with an
alien okay so maybe an intimate Alien
Encounter wouldn't work out that way but
if you believe the statistics 6% of
Americans have allegedly been abducted
by aliens according to these victims the
experiences were intrusive and
horrifying why would an alien want to
mate with a
human well if these aliens wanted to
settle on Earth interbreeding could
speed up the process yeah the child
would have the best of both worlds
combining our DNA could create a hybrid
being that could survive in the hottest
climates and maybe your kids would get
the intelligence of of an alien they
flew across the universe in a tin plate
they have to be a little bright but even
if your Offspring became a genius would
Society ever accept
them hybridization occurs when two
different species breed and it's more
common than you might think we
crossbreed fruits and animals all the
time but this isn't like your mom's
Labradoodle you you would be mating with
a being from another galaxy so what are
the consequences of this
pairing well first forget the wine and
dine scenario from before the only way
you could mate with ET would be through
artificial
insemination after all all of our parts
may not be compatible so whether your
seed was placed in an alien or vice
versa medical procedures would be the
only way to bring your child into this
world unfortunately the real threat to
this kid's health could lie within
you sometimes a mother's blood can
produce antibodies that destroy their
baby's blood cells in humans we call
this condition reesus disease
introducing a completely different blood
type and DNA into a human mother could
trigger their immune system to reject
this perceived alien Intruder and if
their body kept the baby alive long
enough to fully form the next challenge
would be getting it out a child birth
with human babies can be difficult
enough a hybrid birth would definitely
cause
complications to keep the baby hybrid
and its mother safe during labor doctors
would have to perform a cesarian section
yeah those big gray heads aren't getting
through through a birth canal provided
those are some of the physical features
your baby would have the first
generation of hybrids would still look
like their alien side of the family but
the second generation could look so
close to humans you may not even tell
the difference they might be able to
blend into a crowd Although our entire
Society could change with aliens walking
among us and this may not be the first
time humans have made it outside our
species in modern history yeah rumors
still float around about Florida
scientists who artificially inseminated
a chimpanzee with human DNA in the
1920s while we may never know the truth
behind this experiment were it true this
Humane would have been an ethical
nightmare cool name though a human alien
hybrid could hold the answer to our
Survival on a changing Earth or even
beyond the stars the cultural and
physical differences might be too much
to accept at first remember we all still
carry the genes of neander TS in our DNA
the last traces of this long extinct
species that lived alongside humans tens
of thousands of years
ago but hey we got over that
problem
we are
Venom what do you get when you take an
Alien Parasite and smush it together
with a human being would you get to
become a supercharged he eating
anti-hero like Venom or would you die a
slow and painful death uh I never
thought I'd say this but I think I I
prefer to be the guy who eats people's
heads
off I have a parasite today you're
getting infected with your very own
Alien
Parasite how would it mess with your
brain would you lose control of your
body and what's it like to share a body
with
Venom you are the loser this is what if
and here's what would happen if you got
infected by an Alien
Parasite with the release of Venom Let
There Be Carnage we've been thinking
nonstop about
symbiotes but before we infect you with
a parasite from outer space let's
introduce you to your body's new
roommate Venom is a sentient amorphous
Alien Parasite called a symbiote
symbiotes infect and and hijack their
host's bodies taking on portions of
their host's
personality for example you throw one on
a friendly neighborhood Spider-Man you
get an edgy
webslinger if you do the same to a
serial killer you're going to get
something like
Carnage thankfully the relationship
between venom and his human host Eddie
Brock is more akin to an old married
couple a very dangerous old married
couple but you uh we're not sure you'll
be so lucky first the Symbiote would
make its way into your brain uh what
would Venom do up there well we may find
our answer in a parasite that didn't
come from outer space but from cat
poop Toxoplasma Gand aka the feline
parasite is a micro microscopic
neurological parasite known for altering
the behavior of sheep goats pigs cows
rats and well yeah cats while in the
stomach of their carrier host the itty
bitty parasite eggs called
oyes morph into dangerous microbes
called tacazo ites Next the parasite
starts setting up shop in your body and
makes a move on your brain Studies have
shown that rats infected with Toxoplasma
gandi have their brains so rewired by
the parasite that it causes them to get
a little frisky when they smell cats
which as you can guess goes about as
well as trying to get a smooch from
carage and if that wasn't freaky enough
did you know that this parasite may have
already infected 30 % of the human
population including 60 million
Americans yeah ever since the start of
the 20th century when we started getting
into cats as pets as the number of
domesticated kitties grew so did cases
of
schizophrenia researchers have linked
this Spike to an increase in the
presence of Toxoplasma gandi in
humans well your parasite didn't want to
be buddies like Venom it wants to use
you as food kind of like the corps
fungus you know that super disturbing
zombie ant fungi when the ceps fungus
takes over an ant it forces that little
worker to bite down on a leaf and stay
put until it dies in the meantime the
parasite feeds off the ant for 3 weeks
growing out of the ant's head and
creating more infectious
spores this wouldn't look good for you
either with your infection the parasite
would know that you're smarter than some
blue collar worker ant meaning it
wouldn't try to take over your nervous
system instead it would go right to
taking control of your muscles all while
you helplessly
watch so it seems sharing your body with
a parasite is isn't quite the comic book
adventure Venom makes it out to be and
if it's anything like the Lowa Lowa
eyeworm it sounds
terrifying measuring up to 10 mm in
length the eyeworm can hide away in the
human tissue anywhere from 10 to 15
years yeah it also does this cute little
thing where it squirms across your
eyeball leaving larvae in its wake if
these larv get close enough to your
thinker you could develop brain disease
like
encylopedic I we'd recommend holding off
starting your life as a superhero and
maybe take a trip to your nearest
emergency room
[Applause]
instead attention human you are
receiving an inter Stellar radio
transmission and it could be coming from
one of the nearest exoplanets Proxima
centor
B what conditions make this planet a
candidate for alien
life what types of civilizations could
have flourished there and should we
expect them to be knocking on Earth's
door any day
now this is what if and here's what
would happen if if there were an alien
civilization on Proxima
B at a distance of 4.2 light years away
Proxima centu is one of the closest
stars to our sun in
2016 a planet was discovered orbiting in
Proxima Cent's goldilock Zone that's
where conditions for liquid water could
exist meet Proxima b a planet that
registers at Z
.87 on the earth similarity Index this
scale measures how similar a planet or
moon is to Earth and anything above 0.8
is considered earthlike as another
example Mars has an ESI of
0.64 in
2020 astronomers recorded a mysterious
radio signal coming from the direction
of Proxima centor could it be that an
alien civilization was attempting to
contact
us though Proxima B is similar to Earth
life forms on this Alien Planet would
likely develop very differently for
starters the planet is about 20 times
closer to its star than Earth is to the
sun and it only needs 11.2 days for one
full Revolution that's a lot of New
Year's celebrations but still Proxima B
receives about the same amount of solar
energy as Earth and that's because
Proxima centu is an M type Red Dwarf
star compared to our gtype star these
stars are generally cooler in a range of
2200 to 3200 de
C but there would be some extreme
conditions that an alien civilization
would have to adapt to these
extraterrestrials would need to be able
to withstand stand radiation and lots of
it the planet receives about 400 times
more x-rays than Earth and dwarf stars
like proximus Sor give rise to coronal
mass ejections that would blast the
planet with lethal
radiation without a protective
atmosphere this would be deadly for any
potential life forms another challenge
for approxima B civilization would be
tidal locking that's when a planet takes
the same amount of time to spin on its
axis as it does to orbit its star
imagine living where you permanently
face the scorching sun while the other
side of the earth is in a constant state
of Frozen
Darkness this is what life would be like
on this exoplanet civilizations on
Proxima B would likely develop in the
so-called Terminator zones these are the
strips of Twilight between the day side
and the night side here winds would
carry warm air and create lifeup
supporting conditions and Aliens would
build thermal reactors with the mix of
cool and hot water to have that H2O
always
available but if civilizations appeared
on either of the sides of the Terminator
Zone they'd need to develop different
survival tactics but collaboration and
unity could allow them to supply each
other other with heat or ice effectively
and if a civilization developed on the
light side would they even know that
there were other stars or objects in the
universe would they even think about
other life out in
space that brings us back to the radio
signal the Breakthrough listen project
recorded in
2020 this signal occupied a very narrow
band of the radio spectrum at 900 82
mahz this is startling because it's a
portion of the spectrum rarely used by
human-made
transmitters researchers haven't ruled
out the possibility that these signals
originated on Earth but there are many
unanswered questions one thing they're
sure of it didn't come from a natural
world only manufactured or alien-made
technology seems to produce signals like
that
so if an advanced civilization was
trying to communicate with us from
Proxima B what would their society be
like they could be a type one
civilization like us and use the energy
available from their Planet like oil
wind or geothermal power or they could
be a type 2 civilization using energy on
the scale of their planetary system that
would mean they were thousands of years
more advanced than us would they have
developed complex languages and live in
cities would they have Democratic forms
of governance or would they live under
the rule of a
dictator you must have so many questions
for our alien neighbors and they would
have so many questions for you or maybe
they already know
everything
unfortunately we likely won't be able to
visit them anytime soon using current
Technologies it would still take between
19,000 81,000 years to reach
[Music]
them just north of the Martian equator
lies a 45 km wide impact crater that
scientists believe may have been the
sight of an ancient Lake here at jazero
Crater scientists theorize that its
frozen soil may contain the most
significant discovery of
humankind
life on February 18th
2021 NASA's perseverance Rover started
searching this crater to find out if
we're truly
alone what is the likelihood of Life on
Mars what would these Martians look
like and how will we send samples back
to
Earth this is what if and here's what
would happen if we discovered Life on
Mars as Scientific American puts it it
would take a near miracle for Mars to be
sterile astrobiologist Chris McKay at
Nasa believes that Earth and Mars have
been sharing materials for billions of
years kind of like using your roommates
spice rack what I thought you said it
was
communal comets or large meteorites that
have hit Earth may have also sent debris
onto Mars a tiny fraction of this debris
on Mars could have carried the same
microbes that kickstarted Life as we
know it on Earth but what would this
alien life look
like many scientists agree that whatever
life on Mars we might find would need to
be incredibly robust with the
combination of radiation and freezing
temperatures on Mars could any life form
survive such a harsh
environment as far-fetched as it sounds
microbiologists have discovered many
organisms that thrive in extreme
environments the tardigrade or water
bear is a highly resistant extrem mile
it can withstand heat cold pressure
radiation and even a complete lack of
oxygen there are also certain types of
bacteria on Earth that rapidly produce
spores when faced with hazardous
conditions the bacteria can then
hibernate during an extended period of
Dr and withstand intense ionizing
radiation a team of 1,000 geologists
chemists physicists and biologists
worldwide have drilled 4.8 km into the
Earth and discovered robust life forms
Mars has a similar geological past to
Earth so looking underground could be a
great place to
start by drilling into the gzero crater
we could encounter spores associated
with a relatively recent geological era
and on future missions to Mars we may
dig deeper and uncover fully vegetative
microbes to find rock samples that might
support life NASA's perseverance Rover
uses an array of lasers called a super
cam it can study the surface of Mars at
a distance one of the lasers will heat a
rock sample and vaporize it this creates
a plasma that can be analyzed to
understand its Elemental composition
another laser will reveal which
compounds are in the dirt if the super
cam detects organic molecules or
elevated concentrations of elements like
nitrogen or phosphorus the Rover will
head over to take a closer look it will
then scan the soil in Greater detail to
detect any organic material hiding in
the
dirt NASA's team on Earth has only one
shot at picking the right spot to gather
these samples with limited space on
board the Rover only a few dozen samples
can be collected so no pressure and
fingers
crossed if all goes well NASA plans to
bring back samples known for preserving
bio signatures on Earth bio signatures
are faint molecular traces left behind
by microbes billions of years ago once
the samples are collected NASA and the
European Space Agency plan two missions
to get them back to Earth this involves
blasting tubes of rock and soil samples
into orbit to be collected by another
spacecraft and then return to Earth wa
this looks kind of
fun if perseverance is mission is
successful the discovery of Life on Mars
would be as groundbreaking as the
Discover of
DNA in
1543 Copernicus boldly shook the status
quo with his theory that the planets
orbited the sun his discoveries
completely changed our worldview no
longer putting Earth at the center of
the
universe discovering life beyond Earth
could be just as
powerful but not finding any life could
raise more questions is the earth truly
special
are we alone out
here even if we don't discover Life
these Martian Rock samples will allow
chemists to study the geochemistry
minerology and foundational Bedrock
materials of Mars in
detail this could provide us with
essential insights into the climate
history of Mars and help us better
understand earth's climate as
well in
1976 two Viking Landers became the first
spacecrafts from Earth to touch down on
Mars they too probed for life in the
Martian soil and the results are still
debated to this day one experiment
indicated that the Martian soil tested
positive for
metabolism on Earth this would almost
certainly suggest the presence of life
but another related experiment found no
trace of organic material whatsoever
While most scientists have not
reconciled the conflicting results the
consensus is that there's no conclusive
evidence of Life on Mars but several
researchers disagree recent discoveries
of terrestrial microorganisms surviving
outside of the ISS indicate that life
may be resilient enough for Mars and
methane in the Martian atmosphere could
be a sign of microbial
methanogens a type of microorganism that
produces a significant amount of methane
stinky
aliens mind you it's possible that life
on Mars didn't have the right conditions
to start at all or maybe it died off
from an Extinction event similar to the
asteroid that wiped out the dinosaurs or
it's even possible that we might end up
finding life that was accidentally
brought to Mars by one of our many
Rovers
let's hope this perseverance Mission
doesn't turn into a $2.7 billion face
palm if Mars is your bag well have you
ever thought about setting up shop there
with recent developments in
rocketry colonizing Mars might be
possible In Our
Lifetime this just in visitors from
beyond the stars have arrived What
secrets could our Intergalactic friends
share what wonders could these space
Chums
unveil they do not come in peace the
aliens have arrived and they're here to
lay down the law humans are no longer at
the top of the food chain and we're now
at the mercy of our alien
overlords I for one welcome our alien
overlords what would our new alien
Masters do with us
and why did they invade
Earth this is what if and here's what
would happen if we became enslaved by
aliens for centuries humans have been
calling the shots on Earth just ask the
animals we use as food keep in zoos hunt
for sport or even have around the house
as pets we're in for quite the shock
when our new Intergalactic master ERS
show up and give us a taste of our own
medicine what exactly would they do to
us well we may become the new animals
we'd be treated as a commodity to be
bought traded and sold and if these
aliens are anything like we are we'd
also be their
lunch human cells are made up of
proteins nucleic acids and membranes if
the aliens had the same basic
biochemistry as us they would be able to
convert our tasty nourishment filled
bodies into energy for themselves would
aliens start farming us on mass what
sort of Intergalactic economy could be
created by using humans like
Livestock in China alone the pork
industry is worth $128
billion and has 433 million pigs ready
to barbecue there are 17 times as many
humans on the planet to an alien food
connoisseur would we be just as tasty
human Burger anyone what if we were seen
as a delicacy to be distributed Across
the
Universe or what about just pieces of
human even to us body parts are a hot
commodity a heart is $1.4 million to
transplant and worth
$119,000 on the open market kidneys are
around the $200,000 Mark liers are
157,000 and bone marrow is
$23,000 a gam we're dealing with human
economics here but this idea can be
applied to the concept that we are
Earth's new cattle we're a living
organism that might be sold to someone
or something somewhere where in
space but what if the aliens didn't
think we were
delicious what if they thought we were
cute well in the US there are nearly 70
million dogs being kept as pets and 74
million cats Brazil has 191 million
feathered best friends would the aliens
keep us as pets or even worse what if
they kept us in captivity and gawked at
us you know like we do with animals in
zoos there are approximately 6,000
species in zoos around the world about 8
million animals in total the aliens may
not have as much Variety in human zoos
but we sure are an entertaining Bunch
imagine a group of alien children on a
school trip watching you in your natural
habitat sea children lectures the alien
head mistress the human is on its phone
again so there's not a lot to look
forward
to but it makes us think about what the
aliens would get out of Earth in the
first place well the earth looks like a
nice place to set up shop on paper Earth
has plate tectonics that help to keep
the climate stable a global magnetic
field that keeps solar winds from
getting close and the added bonus of a
moon that stops Earth from wobbling on
its axis too much that combination would
look appealing to the aliens and it's
something they might have a difficult
time finding anywhere
else and what about us well we already
know we'd not only be delicious but
profitable with the aliens having a
monopoly on the human Market they could
start making more rewarding changes to
their new home considering that their
intelligent enough to travel light years
to get here how hard could it be to
redevelop a
planet the truth is we don't know for
sure what the aliens plans would be this
is only one of several scenarios that
could happen if we faced an alien
[Music]
invasion scientists have pieced together
a pretty clear picture of what life was
like on Earth thousands even millions of
years ago but if you fast forward 1
million years from now would alien
civilization be doing the same to learn
about
us what would Earth look like 1 million
years from
now what remains of human civilization
would still be
around and would we end up clones in a
human version of Jurassic Park
this is what if and here's what would
happen if aliens came to Earth a million
years in the
future we're living in The anthropos
Scene Epic and in this historical period
the human impact on the world around us
has been significant enough to
geologically alter it 100 years from now
it could be an era defined by ecological
collapse and Mass Extinction big bummer
right now there's no way for us to know
how or when our species may take its
final walk on our home planet a team of
alien scientists could find evidence of
nuclear fallout climate change or maybe
a massive asteroid that ended our
existence or maybe they'd even find us
already living on another
planet maybe 1 million ion years from
now you'd be an alien on board a
Starship that has just entered into
orbit around Earth I can't tell if
you're joking or not but despite your
best efforts to scan the planet below
for intelligent life you'd find nothing
your trip down to the surface would be
slightly delayed by an ongoing super
volcanic eruption the planet would be
blanketed in the darkness of Ash you
might even have to wait a few years for
your alien crew to clean it up before
you could even
land finally you get approval to visit
Earth down there you'd find everything
to be Barren and
lifeless storms fires and earthquakes
would have erased nearly all signs of
immediately visible life but your team
of archaeologists and paleontologists
would know that if they wanted to find
evidence of past
civilizations they better start digging
you'd be investigating what are called
boundary layers these are geological
signatures that indicate a transition
from one period to the next so you'd be
looking for animal and plant fossils as
well as changes in rock layers you could
find a thin layer of clay that marks the
boundary to our anthropocenic era the
top layer would contain not much more
than small fossilized remains of a few
plant species the layer below would
contain older rock but not only that
there would be an abundance of diverse
plant fossils this would be a
breakthrough for your team as they now
confirm there was some form of mass
extinction
period as you searched through this
layer the nature of what happened to
Earth over the past million years would
be revealed you'd discover an unnatural
amount of carbon deposits from fossil
fuel emissions evidence of global
temperature changes and widespread
chemical
pollutants but the effects of climate
change may have reversed themselves over
the 1 million years humans have been
absent if your team were to uncover the
regions where our Coastal populations
used to be you could excavate the
remains of cities relatively well
preserved in the sedimentary rock
imagine discovering the ancient subway
tunnels and SE of New York but nothing
you would find would be in pristine
condition bricks would have gone from
their characteristic red TO gray and
steel would have rusted and dissolved
leaving only imprints in the
soil finally you'd make the biggest
discovery of all fossilized human
bones just like the dinosaurs these too
would most likely only be found encased
in sedimentary rock almost all of the
fossils of dinosaurs that we discover
today are from species that would have
lived near lakes or rivers that flooded
floods covered their remains in mud and
silt very quickly and this prevented
their bones from rotting the same would
apply to Homo sapiens your alien team
would piece together the puzzle that
many of these human fossils were the
result of catastrophic floods or
tsunamis and based on how much the Bones
have fused with the Rocks around them
your team could start to assemble a
timeline of our unfortunate
demise usually bones take decades to
decompose if buried in a dry environment
like a funeral casket they could last
for 100 years mummified bones can
survive thousands of years finding any
of these would tell your team that the
last humans to walk the earth weren't
all that far in the past
but discovering only fossilized remains
would reveal our Extinction point being
further back than you'd hoped there
wouldn't be any samples of soft tissues
like muscles just rocks that used to be
bones oh but you'd probably find
fossilized plastic in the layers of
sedimentary rock too it's not yet known
how long plastic waste needs to
decompose into organic matter it could
take hundreds of years maybe
thousands or as you and your crew could
discover
Millions what you'd keep your hopes up
for would be the real Holy Grail human
DNA the oldest DNA samples found in our
modern times date back
800,000 years and come from insects and
plants but studies conclude that DNA
could take about 7 million years to
disintegrate and Eureka you'd find human
DNA samples trapped in ice cores in what
was once Greenland now the big question
would be what do you do with them study
human genetics for scientific purposes
or have a little fun one idea would be
to clone these ancient humans you could
even create some kind of Jurassic Park
filled with people they accept it would
be called anthropos Park
and based on all that you'd put together
about our tragic history there would be
so many entertaining things to do in
this amusement park maybe you could
clone other animals and play a game of
mass extinction the winner would be the
one who could kill the most species in
the shortest amount of time you could
dig for hidden oil reserves increase
carbon emissions for fun to watch
icebergs melt or how about a game of
nuclear war
sadly though you and the other
scientists probably wouldn't be able to
figure out what life was like for humans
at the end of our
civilization we might not be alone in
the
universe scientists from all over the
world have their eyes and ears wide open
trying to detect signals of life beyond
our planet but we're a bit tired of just
sitting and waiting so hop on our
spacecraft because today you have a very
important mission to search for alien
life how would we prepare for this
journey what kind of life would we be
looking
for and what would happen if we found
it this is what if and here's what would
happen if we went on a search for alien
life so far we've detected over 4,000
exoplanets in our galaxy and there may
be as many as
trillions to make your Expedition easier
you'd need to consult with NASA first
NASA has developed the confidence of
Life detection scale or cold to measure
progress in life detection research the
scale has seven levels ranging from
signal detection to follow-up studies
once life beyond Earth is
confirmed first you'd need to look for
Bio
signatures this is physical evidence of
past or present life on another planet
such as chemical compounds or molecules
that indicate biological
processes if an alien astronomer was
taking measurements of Earth they'd look
for oxygen and methane those are bio
signatures that indicate life on our
planet if you're a Celestial technology
geek you might scan for techno
signatures these are signs showing the
negative uses of technology that cause
artificial air pollution this means
aliens could figure out we exist because
of all that smog we send into the
atmosphere embarrassing right now that
you know what to look for where would
you look for it
you could start this search in our own
Cosmic backyard alien life could be
hiding on the subsurface oceans of
Europa one of Jupiter's moons or deep
beneath the surface of Mars ground
telescopes have already detected methane
on Mars sending probes to measure
surface levels that already puts you on
the second level of the cold scale or
you could go further and look for alien
life on rocky planets outside our solar
system you'd need to locate planets
orbiting a star in its habitable zone
that's the area where a planet is not
too close to the star and not too far
allowing for temperatures to be just
right for liquid water to form
scientists have already done the hard
work for you here using the Kepler
object of Interest exoplanet archive
researchers identified systems that
might have rocky planet that meet the
criteria they found 24 super habitable
planets and one of them is very
promising koi
[Music]
that makes koi
post Life The Next Step would be to
predict what type of source could
generate such a signal scientists would
need to confirm this signature couldn't
have come from a non-biological Source
once that was done you'd be on level
four of the cold scale at this level
scientists would test the signal with
other Advanced measurement methods
NASA's powerful James web Space
Telescope would confirm the exoplanet
contains a strong signature for life and
you would be able to proudly say you
found alien life and then scientists
would be able to Kickstart follow-up
studies at level seven that means you'd
now be ready to fasten your seat belt
and see these aliens for
yourself but how would you get
there yeah that's when things get tricky
koi
almost 3,000 light years away from us
that's 700 times further away than
Proxima centor the closest start to our
solar system if we used developing ionic
propulsion engines it would take over 55
million years to get
there wow you'd have to make use of some
futuristic Solutions like a laser sail
this technology uses ultra thin mirrors
to capture the momentum of light from
stars and then uses this momentum to
push a spacecraft to high
speeds if you managed to build laser
sails with diameters of 320 km you might
be able to reach koi 571 5.01 in about
8,500 years setting aside the fact that
you wouldn't live that long what would
you find once you got
there alien life could be extremely
complex or very basic and the alien's
appearance would depend on the world
they evolved on things like gravity
density and the amount of energy given
off by its star they would probably have
something that resembles fingers or
tentacles to build tools and since two
legs and two arms are more efficient
than four legs the aliens might have
evolved to walk upright you want to
invite them for a
stroll well first you'd need to figure
out there while your journey to find
alien life might be successful in our
hypothetical story in reality it's still
very far-fetched
with technology evolving to detect
signals from outer space we might be
able to identify them at some point but
there would still be the issue of
getting to
[Music]
them this not so little piece of
equipment could change astronomy
forever and it could be about to find
alien life maybe in a matter of
days what is this powerful new
tool how could it detect life in
galaxies far
away and if it does find life what would
happen
next this is what if and here's what
would happen if the James web telescope
found alien
life the James web Space Telescope
launched into space on December 25th
2021 its mission to study the history of
our
universe from the Afterglow of the Big
Bang to the formation of solar systems
like our own this large infrared
telescope is 100 times more powerful
than the Hubble telescope it has 18
separate mirror and a half million kilom
away from the earth it should be able to
see us
first if you were looking for signs of
Life on distant exoplanets you wouldn't
look for little green alien
you'd look for Bio
signatures in other words
characteristics in a planet's atmosphere
that could be evidence of life in the
past or present imagine an alien
astronomer From A Distant Galaxy
pointing a telescope toward Earth the
bio signatures they'd make note of are
the presence of oxygen and methane in
our atmosphere without life forms
breathing these two gases in and out
these elements would react with others
and disappear so the James web telescope
will look for the presence of oxygen and
methane too first you'd need to detect
the presence of an exoplanet around a
distant star you could do this through
the transit method as a planet passes in
front of a star you'd observe its light
slightly
diminishing after that planet passes in
front of its star many times you'd have
enough data to take measurements of its
atmosphere you'd be able to see how much
light goes through its atmosphere and
you could determine what atmospheric
elements exist there based on the way
the light
disperses with a telescope as powerful
as the web you could gather enough data
after a planet has passed its Star as
few as five to 10 times yeah so after
only 20 hours of investigating a planet
you could detect conditions for life but
then what 100% for sure going to die
well you probably wouldn't go public
with this information right away you'd
probably want to follow the confidence
of Life detection scale commonly
referred to as cold this is an approach
that scientists at Nasa are looking to
establish if would set up a new
framework for discussing how close we
are to finding life beyond our
planet the scale would have seven levels
level one would be the detection of Bio
signatures as more data is collected
you'd climb the scale to level seven at
this point you'd likely find alien life
and that's when the whole world freaks
out and powerful alien beam down to
conquer our planet
right not
exactly if we discover Life using the
web telescope it would be more than
likely that we are the powerful
intelligent beings the bombshell
announcement of alien life would be a
lot less dramatic than the movies
suggest it could take decades be
prepared for a slow progression of
countless many
announcements and remember that the
distances between Earth and exoplanets
of Interest are vast so if you decided
to take an Interstellar trip to one of
those like the exoplanet Trappist 1e it
would take you
decades but scientists believe that this
planet may have atmospheric conditions
similar to ours or at least least
similar to the Earth 2 and 1/2 to 4
billion years ago so maybe we could find
microscopic life there a discovery like
this would elicit many different
reactions for you it could be a dream
come true but for others it could be
concerning it could affect your entire
understanding of life in the
[Music]
universe
are we alone in the
universe with more than 100 billion
galaxies in the observable universe and
at least 500 billion planets in the
Milky Way alone don't you think we
should have found something by
now even if a tiny percentage of those
billions of planets hosted intelligent
life there would be tens of thousands of
extraterrestrial civilizations out there
yet we haven't seen any where is
everybody we keep wondering what's
taking them so long to come but what if
I told you that even the friendliest of
all aliens could wipe out our entire
civilization for
good this is what if and here's what
would happen if aliens visited us
[Music]
tomorrow
we tend to apply our theories to the
rest of the universe we expect aliens to
come for a visit even though we
ourselves haven't traveled out of our
own neighborhood yet we just believe
that they've had so much more time for
technological progress to make space
travel possible so here they are with
their shiny alien spaceship roving above
our heads what would we
do as far as we know no government on
this planet has any sort of alien
greeting party planned if aliens
suddenly showed up on the
horizon just try to keep
cool say the aliens happen to be very
polite and sent us a signal before
invading our planet's personal
space well you wouldn't know it right
away not until several observatories
maintained by different organizations
verified that
signal yep that's it aliens are here now
you know you got this shocking news from
your TV NASA officially confirms an
alien ship detected in the solar system
not alone in the
[Music]
University agencies and countries around
the world would be working together
quickly trying to assess the level of
threat they'd summon experts in
linguistics psychology combat and
biology and have them attempt to make
first contact with the
aliens groups of experts would record
all interactions to analyze simp alien
gestures and auditory
reactions those would help to decide
whether aliens came at peace or they
intend to do some serious
damage some people might believe that
religious leaders should do all the
Talking something's telling me that
aliens didn't learn our languages in
school so good luck to anyone trying to
reach out to
them while the world's most intelligent
people were busy trying to interpret the
aliens intentions to the best of their
ability you would be wait aren't you
curious to know what the aliens look
like some Evolution experts agree that
things like proteins and DNA are the
same no matter where in the universe
you're from if that's true alien
Evolution would be close to that of
humans they'd have binocular vision with
eyes located close to the brain just
like us they'd be based on land and have
a minimum of two legs for mobility and
three fingers so that they could handle
tools still if some of our own life
forms look like this try to picture
something coming from another
planet meanwhile on Earth while
governments were busy figuring out the
action plan the media would be keeping
you informed city has come an
absolute you'd be advised to stay
indoors and wait for further
instructions it' be hard to filter out
what's legitimate new news and what
isn't but try not to fall for fake end
of thee world news on Facebook and keep
calm at least make an effort to give up
the urge to pack up your belongings and
head for the
hills at the same time the governments
and scientific experts would be sharing
information about alien
interactions from here the events could
unfold in a few different ways first we
may not get any auditory or visual
response nothing at
all this could mean anything from the
alien spacecraft doesn't have any aliens
on board to the aliens are waiting for
their alien backup to fry us
up another possibility is that aliens
responded and tried to communicate with
no weapons involved I can't speak to
their possible intentions for all we
know they may want to get rid of us and
keep the Earth to themselves thanks to
the language barrier our interactions
might not be going well tensions would
begin to rise we'd be
screwed considering that these beings
had the technology to travel to earth
it's likely that they also had the
capability to develop some very very
Advanced
Weaponry civilians would most likely be
hitting the Panic Button as hard as
possible meanwhile governments would put
their nuclear weapons on standby
that will be our best and most
destructive weapon against
them or so we think it may turn out that
the aliens have adverse reactions to
things on earth that we're all
accustomed
to if say they're skin melted upon
contact with water then defending
ourselves against them would be
simple I'm not saying aliens would
necessarily bring Doom upon the Earth
they may not mean us any harm at
all but if some hazardous microorganisms
from outer space hitched a ride with
them and made it into our world we
humans might have no natural immunity to
those extraterrestrial microbes and they
could slowly wipe our species off the
planet on the other hand if aliens
weren't coming here to make friends we'd
be destroyed long before we got a chance
to offer peace between intelligent
beings in any case we aren't ready for a
visit from interplanetary Travelers we'd
better get prepared for First
Contact or maybe we should try to invade
alien worlds before they invade
us but that's a topic for another what
[Music]
if
billions of years ago another planet
smashed into Earth an event of this
epicness could have created our moon it
also could have brought a